a chance to reset ties the French
President warmly welcoming the UK prime
minister in Paris for the first
franco-british summit in five years
relations between Paris and London have
been strained since brexit but the war
in Ukraine's helped improve them by
creating a common sense of purpose after
their meeting macron sunak pledged
continuing support for Kiev and to
jointly train Ukrainian forces
we are both U.N security Council Members
founding members of NATO two Powers with
real shared interests and we want to
work together to build Concrete
Solutions for our future
it was a change of tone from recent
years France and Britain have rowed over
issues including fishing whites covid
and a submarine contract tensions
continue to simmer though over
cross-channel migration the UK is on
call for France to do more to stop the
people it says arriving in Britain
illegally buy small boats France has
long said it needs more money to do so
sunak said Britain will now give France
more than 570 million dollars over three
years to help
we're announcing a new Detention Center
in northern France a new Command Center
bringing our enforcement teams together
in one place for the first time and an
extra 500 new officers patrolling French
beaches my cross certainly seems to have
a much better working relationship with
sunak than he had with former British
prime ministers list Russell Boris
Johnson and this Summit was very much an
opportunity to show that France and
Britain are very much United
revived ties between Europe's biggest
military and only nuclear Powers sends a
clear message to Moscow but it's also
likely to play out well for domestic
audiences at a time of social unrest in
both countries
in France or in the UK the each leader
face huge domestic issues to say less so
it's always good in that context to have
a kind of diplomatic success or sunax
visit to Paris will be followed later
this month by Britain's new King Charles
who's chosen France for his first over
trip another sign that despite some
differences France and Britain's
historic Alliance still stands Natasha
Butler Al Jazeera Paris